i saw mike lindell is in the news you
know mike lindell show his picture he's
the my pillow guy
big trump supporter super christian
conspiracy theorist
former crackhead i'm not saying that as
a slam or a slur that he is very honest
about it
anyway he's getting
reformed his life very good
look how easy it is to get them to
applaud um
he's being sued by the dominion voting
machine company for 1.3 billion
because he keeps claiming that the
election was rigged and phony and all
that so apparently he's not going to go
away
we thought it'd be a very good week to
do 24 things you don't know
about the my pillow guy mike lindell 24
things
i i only switched over to my pillow
after my sock didn't take off
in high school i was voted most likely
to sell a sack of foam to idiots
i no longer do drugs i just sound like i
do
mike lindell i took the mastermind out
of criminal mastermind
when i was a crack addict i knew i'd hit
rock bottom
when i thought about selling my bottom
for a rock
i'm a christian and the bible says
homosexuality is a sin
but sometimes a guy's got to score an
eight ball again we're just kidding
he he didn't do that we're just making
jokes mike pence says my pillow i'm
sorry his favorite to bite
i'm an evangelical christian if you were
a who made 300 million
selling pillows you believe in god all
too
you